Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to have a look at the
incredible capabilities of Midjourney,
a text to image AI that creates fantasy
images that are so good that it’s frankly
almost unbelievable. It is
a league above any other AI
I have seen so far. I’ll show you 5
of my favorite examples in a moment.
Now, what is this? Text to image means exactly
what it says, we write a short description,
and the AI paints our image. But
things are changing now. We may
not even need to be writing our own
prompts. What? Why is that? Well,
the GPT-4 AI also just came out, this can be
used with ChatGPT, OpenAI’s amazing assistant.
And, one, hold on to your papers, because we
can ask it to break down the key elements of
food photography, what kinds of food should
we use, what should the background look like,
what about lighting, composition, and so much
more. Photography is an art after all. So,
what did we get here? Did we get some sort of
tutorial, or some ideas? Well, don’t forget,
this is a chat assistant, so we can ask it to
tabulate all these ideas, and, oh yes! We get a
table with detailed instructions for each photo.
These instructions can be dumped into a prompt,
which ChatGPT will happily do for us, and
then, what do we do with this? Of course,
we give this to MidJourney and create these
beautiful hamburgers. Look, these instructions
were truly amazing. We can go for a retro-style
top-view, or, if this made us super hungry,
and we wish to get over the top, we can do this
too. All with the help of two AIs combined. Wow.
The same concept can be applied
to interior design as well. The
lighting and the mood on this one results
in a stunning picture. I don’t know about
you but I still cannot believe that an
AI made this. Or, two AIs if you will.
Now, two we can also create not only
images, but videos with these methods.
Look. If we have made a character that has
the right look, but not quite the right age,
or we wish to age this character over time, we can
do that too. This video is not to be used as-is,
so it should not be confused by techniques
that are specifically tailored for that. But,
if we stop it at individual frames,
these can be used as images.
Three, it is now able to do something that
none of the previous text to image AIs were
able to. Interestingly, none of the previous
previous techniques were unable to synthesize
human hands with 5 fingers. Also, they were
often not quite the right shape. And…can that
really be? Is it finally solved? Look.
So, let’s see this one. Wow. Now those
are not only 5 fingers everywhere, but the
detail and the variety of these images are
absolutely incredible. I will now officially
allow it to give a big thumbs up to itself.
Four, MidJourney is currently on version 5, and
I found it really surprising that improvement has
still not plateaued. For instance, in version
4, it imagined holograms and people to look
like this, which is not too great. But the same
prompts on version 5. Now that’s what I am talking
about. And just imagine what version 7 will
be capable of two more versions down the line.
But we are not done yet. Not even close!
Five, we have a few more amazing results,
and look who this one is coming from. Yes, that’s
right, the legendary computer graphics researcher,
Donald Mitchell. Among many other things, he is
the author of the legendary Mitchell-Netravali
filter, which contributes to creating beautiful
high-quality images in light transport simulations
and more. He asked for some robot sushi, and
I love how imaginative the results were. These
works both pass for robots, but they also seem
like edible lunch at the same time. Bravo. And,
what better way to wash it down then asking
for a cocktail from an alien planet. One again,
they certainly have a strong alien
feel, and I have to say, some of these
also look drinkable. But, be careful,
who knows what they contain. Loving it.
And plus one because I cannot resist. My
favorite. Perhaps everyone’s favorite.
Macro photos. Close-up photography of typically
small subjects. I have found this apple pie and
this dragon eye, not only the best AI-made
macro images I’ve ever seen, but these are
so good they might even rival a journeyman
photographer’s images. What a time to be alive!
I will note that here is the point where you
usually get some deeper analysis in the video,
however, it is not possible here. This
work likely builds on previous papers,
but it does not have a paper itself that I know
of. However, if a technical document describing
it appears, I will be very excited to
have a look and show it to you. Also,
I expect that you are excited to
try this. If you wish to try it,
the first 25 images are free. After that,
they are asking for a paid subscription.
So, which image from these was
your favorite? Have you done your
own experiments? Let me know in the comments
below! And for now, let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!